Glen Jacob cane however you know him
he's here in morning studio with us are
y'all have you done research to make
sure that you are the physically biggest
mayor in the in America so there is a
mayor from another County and rural
Tennessee that he's a pretty big cat I
think he's my height really he's a big
dude yeah we could we could we could add
something to the Tennessee Volunteers
offensive line do you play football ever
no I did I did I played the Truman State
University what do you play offensive
tackle of course so when you're at what
point in your life did you start to get
politically motivated and I don't even
mean like thinking that this would be a
career I mean get interested in it
because you've been talking about
economics and politics right for a long
time yeah really I've always been that
way ever since I was a kid I've been
interested in history social studies is
probably my favorite class when I was in
school so it's it I've always been
interested to some extent you know going
through college and get exposed and get
exposed to some some different ideas and
then you get out in the real world and
you know you find out gosh government
takes a lot of money from promise what
does it do with it and sometimes it
doesn't do very good stuff with it so
you know just just throughout my life
I've always been somewhat interested I
never earlier I never would have
considered running for elected office
and right
in fact at a point I said that I never
would ever why would anyone everyone do
that change my mind what's the biggest
surprise you've had like since you get
elected all right you like I think I'm
gonna make a difference I like what's
been the biggest thing like Oh God that
works that way that's awful well you
know I don't know if there's been any
surprises in that respect because I I
went in you know rather don't wanna say
cynical but I think a realist about how
that were operates and it does it does
go slow and there actually is a reason
for that we want accountability we want
transparency and that sort of thing
seriously my biggest surprise is how
much
it is and it really is it's a blast and
I have a lot of fun doing this I mean
you've done a lot of fun things for a
living yeah this feel like well but I
also think it's all everything is what
you make of it yeah and if you if you
concentrate I mean everybody's
everybody's gonna have issues you
understand that you know and if you
concentrate on that all the time
that's what you're gonna you know how
are you gonna feel about things but if
you you know if you concentrate on the
positives and and and trying to have an
impact and trying to do things anything
constructive and doing those in the
right way that's what you're the that's
how your kind of paradigm emerges and
that's what I try to do so when you're
when you decide you're gonna run do you
start painstakingly going through your
wrestling career to figure out okay what
clips are they going to play out of fire
yeah you worry about that stuff but I
also hope that people are mature enough
to understand that that's entertainment
well schwarzenegger got elected so right
right and also i think i think the
stereotype is has changed now which is a
good thing but yeah you know it's always
like someone's gonna say this or that
and you did that people saying that in
the end you just have to you know
whatever it's also got to be nice to
that like since your cane it's like so
super character-driven
right that you're like I'm not the
Undertaker's brother I don't wear a red
mask right you know I'm not related to
pallbearer in any way like this is this
is clearly a soap opera yeah I always
say that you know most politicians are
trying to convince people that the
politician is the person I see on TV in
many cases I was trying to convince them
that I'm not the person like I
personally couldn't separate senator
Brutus the barber beefcake with garden
shears
that's probably not how many candidates
have Undertaker and Rand Paul
[Laughter]
and they're both saying the same thing
he hits hard one more Jim and Sam catch
up with full episodes and interviews
from celebrity guests anytime on demand
using the Sirius XM app
[Music]